victor est le dernier né d'une famille
de trois enfants tous âgés de moins de
cinq ans le temps est une denrée
précieuse dans la famille vernier sharek
et marie claude verrier ne veux pas le
perdre à courir les épiceries donc j'en
fais énormément on joue on extrait en
ligne je fais livrer ensuite pour tout
ce qui est la base les serial le sec les
canucks qui fruits légumes les trucs un
peu plus frais un peu plus spontané ce
j'en fais une partie en ligne qu'une
partie je vais au coin de la rue
l'épicerie en ligne gagne le coeur des
québécois
l'engouement est encore timide certes à
peine 7% adoptent cette façon de faire
ses emplettes mais elle a de plus en
plus la cote
ce sont davantage les adultes âgés de 35
à 54 1 qui font leurs achats
alimentaires année et le temps n'est pas
leur seule motivation il ya un compte et
que j'ai menée qui est un peu moins
motif je vois les spéciaux je planifie
la semaine je fais moins d'achats
spontanés chez avec ce que j'ai besoin
dans la catégorie des achats d'aliments
ligne plusieurs modèles sauf qu'aux
consommateurs
il y a les grands distributeurs provigo
métro et iga est de plus en plus les
entreprises qui prépare les boîtes repas
il s'agit des marchés good food miss
fraîche et à l'eau fraîche de ce monde
qui affiche une croissance importante
les gens veulent économiser du temps
veulent manger sainement en fait le
deuxième anniversaire avec métro depuis
le 2 ans qu'on est avec métro nous on a
vu une croissance de 5 fois on a passé
de 50 à près de 300 employés d'autres
modèles d'affaires de plus en plus
novateurs attire l'attention
hier par exemple la firme maillard qui
offre via un site web 150 différentes
coupes de viande à on n'aurait pas passé
ce seuil il ya une dizaine d'années je
pense que je prends il est envisagé
d'avoir à peu près tout en ligne il y à
un hic cependant par contre je trouve
qu'il ya énormément d'emballage
et beaucoup de suremballage les
entreprises en sont de plus en plus
conscients on aimerait ça également pour
livrer dans ces bacs leur à la maison
avec un modèle de conseils en matière de
commerce électronique le secteur de
l'alimentation est en pleine mutation
l'émergence de nouveaux modèles
d'affaires risque de forcer les
distributeurs traditionnels à être plus
novateurs ici maxime bertrand radio
canada montréal